sicurezza e giustizia riparativa
credo che non si possa parlare di
sicurezza senza partire dalla vittima
dal senso di insicurezza che prova chi
subisce un reato che ha visto tradita la
propria fiducia nell'ordinamento visto
che l'ordinamento non ha saputo
tutelarla e voglio qui non farvi pensare
a reati gravissimi a un omicidio ma
pensiamo a reati comuni pensiamo a un
furto pensiamo a una diffamazione che
non ha mai subito una diffamazione
magari anche commessa cosa succede di
fronte a questi reati
dopo una denuncia dopo una querela si
mette in moto un meccanismo complesso in
cui lo stato incarnato dal pubblico
ministero raccoglierà tutti gli elementi
che sono necessari per capire se
effettivamente si deve dar corso al
processo
se ci sono i presupposti per arrivare ad
un eventuale condanna una condanna ad
una pena che deve essere proporzionata
alla gravità del reato e alla
colpevolezza del reo processo giusto
pena proporzionata
la vittima dove sta la vittima potrebbe
non incontrare mai l'autore del reato e
questo anche qualora volesse incontrarlo
potrebbe leggere il suo nome su una
carta che viene portata a casa di solito
avvolta in una busta verde dove trova
scritto il nome dell'autore di reato
le norme di legge violate un breve
riassunto della vicenda in termini
giuridici il capo di imputazione e
potrebbe addirittura essere chiamata ad
essere presente in udienza una mattina
trascorrere sulle sul corridoio del
tribunale diverse ore per potersi alla
fine a sentir dire che l'autore di reato
ha scelto di patteggiare la pena
magari una pena severa magari una pena
da scontare in carcere ma tutto finisce
lì è questa una vittima più sicura il
modello che conosciamo il modello di
giustizia penale che conosciamo il
modello che in qualche modo e figlio
dell'ideale illuministico per cui la
vittima deve essere disarmata per
ragioni di pace sociale deve cedere allo
stato il potere monopolistico di punti
la pena che si applica una pena
razionalizzata una pena che risponde a
esigenze di pacificazione e allo stesso
tempo di riparazione della vittima
questo secondo l'ideale questo ideale
non possiamo fare passi indietro sul
fronte del garantismo il garantismo è un
risultato irrinunciabile tuttavia ci
siamo anche resi conto di come questa
vittima rischi di essere a volte troppo
marginalizzata di come la vittima spesso
venga doppiamente vittimizzata dal
processo nel processo la vittima viene a
volte sentita come testimone spesso
viene sentita come testimone viene fatta
bersaglio di domande insidiose da parte
della difesa che per giuste ragioni di
garanzia cercherà di minare la
credibilità della vittima la vittima può
essere parte del processo solo se
munendosi di un avvocato chiederà in
sede penale chiede in sede penale un
risarcimento alla fine di un lungo
processo potrà anche ottenere magari
solo sulla carta un risarcimento perché
la capienza patrimoniale dell'autore del
reato non è sufficiente per garantire
alcunché ma questa vittima in questo
quadro che ne restano ancora con maggior
sospetto perché contribuisce in questo
caso strumentalmente alla ricerca della
verità
la vittima in questo quadro è una
vittima che molto spesso rivolge ad alta
voce richieste di pene sempre più severe
del resto sicuramente perché di questo
il sistema non si occupa il sistema che
vi ha descritto non si occupa la vittima
non è una persona che dal reato ha
subito conseguenze esistenziali negative
il sistema non si occupa della
sofferenza della vittima del trauma che
ha subito non se ne deve occupare la
vittima è al massimo qualcuno che dal
reato ci ha rimesso qualcosa
non è un caso quindi che a partire dalla
metà del secolo scorso si sia cominciato
a guardare alla giustizia riparativa con
interesse proprio preoccupandosi di
assicurare alle vittime una tutela più
concreta non è un caso che a partire
dagli anni ottanta del secolo scorso non
vi sia un documento sovranazionale
questo sia a livello delle nazioni unite
che di consiglio d'europa che di unione
europea che si occupi di tutela delle
vittime e non riservi parole
incoraggianti alla giustizia riparativa
ristorati justice nel dibattito
internazionale
vediamo allora di capire senza darvi
definizioni cos'è la giustizia
riparativa darvi un'idea di giustizia
riparativa attraverso tre elementi nella
giustizia riparativa il reato è rottura
di una relazione rottura delle
aspettative sociali simbolicamente
condivise che reato ha portato con sé
secondo elemento
secondo la giustizia riparativa quello
che conta non è tanto punire ma e
riparare riparare le conseguenze
negative del reato mediante azioni
positive che sono naturalmente lasciate
nelle mani dell'autore del reato
e infatti terzo elemento protagonisti
della giustizia riparativa sono i
protagonisti del reato autore del reato
vittima con eventuali rappresentanti
della comunità che se vogliono posso
partecipare a un percorso un percorso
che è sempre e comunque volontario
un percorso in cui le parti
consensualmente possono definire quale
può essere la soluzione adeguata al caso
che li interessa e allora quali sono i
vantaggi sono intuibili
la vittima finalmente a uno spazio in
cui essere riconosciuta uno spazio in
cui viene riconosciuta la dignità della
sua sofferenza uno spazio in cui la
dimensione emozionale del reato viene
considerata uno spazio in cui
raccontarsi in cui raccontare in cui
rivolge all'autore del reato che può
essere presente naturalmente se lo vuole
quelle domande che tutte le vittime si
fanno perché è perché a me si creano le
condizioni per guardare avanti per non
rimanere per non rimanere arroccati per
soli passato per riacquistare quella
sicurezza che ha un presupposto
fondamentale la fiducia nell'ordinamento
dal lato dell'autore risultati sono
ancora più incoraggianti per certi
aspetti è autore di reato può avere
l'occasione di rendersi realmente conto
dei contenuti lesivi del proprio reato
il reato non è più solo una norma
violata perché l'autore ha davanti a sé
per la prima volta che quel reato lo ha
subito la subito sulla propria pelle
in questo caso l'autore di reato può
fare un passo avanti e molti mediatori
protagonisti della giustizia riparativa
di questi percorsi riparativi raccontano
di come con stupore molti ladri autori
di reati contro il patrimonio scoprano
in questi percorsi di come deve loro
reato non abbia semplicemente cagionato
un danno al patrimonio delle vittime
un furto in appartamento magari dal
punto di vista economico non lede un
valore altissimo
il danno non è così elevato ma la vita
delle vittime è profondamente cambiata e
gli autori di reato lo scoprono solo lì
in quel momento
questo tipo di consapevolezza è il
motore di una nuova responsabilizzazione
un'inedita responsabilizzazione e la
riparazione che può opporsi alla fine di
questo percorso in qualche modo
garantisce quella pacificazione che la
pena non sempre riesce a garantire e una
tangibile concreta riparazione per la
vittima quali sono le potenzialità della
giustizia riparativa
in realtà infinite se ci sono reati e ci
sono vittime
c'è spazio per la giustizia riparativa
certo bisogna stare attenti più reati
sono gravi più errati sono violenti e
più bisogna evitare che all'interno di
questi percorsi si riproducano quelle
dinamiche violente che naturalmente
possono verificarsi all'interno di
progetti di processi informali
ci vogliono dei bravi professionisti più
i reati sono gravi più dobbiamo renderci
conto di come tutto ciò non sia
alternativo alla pena e al processo ma
eventualmente tutto ciò si accompagna
questo infatti a me piace pensare alla
giustizia riparativa non come un ideale
lontano dalla realtà ma mi piace pensare
a un dialogo fra la giustizia che vi ho
descritto quella che conosciamo e la
giustizia riparativa
mi piace pensare a una giustizia
tradizionale arricchita della giustizia
riparativa che riceve nuova linfa dalla
giustizia riparativa con degli spazi che
posso trovare in vari momenti li appena
il reato è stato commesso
soprattutto di fronte a reati non gravi
naturalmente
ma frequentissimi errati che sono
espressione di micro conflitti tra
privati e lì un percorso riparativo con
esito positivo poi evitare l'apertura
del procedimento tutto si chiude lì
molto più frequentemente posso pensare a
processi riparativi nel corso del
procedimento che vi ho brevemente
descritto come parentesi parentesi
all'interno del procedimento ordinario
in cui un esito positivo può essere
variamente tradotto per reati meno gravi
tutto può chiudersi con una rapida
uscita dal processo è una rinuncia alla
pena per reati più gravi
potrò valorizzare quella condotta
riparatoria positiva con una sanzione
meno elevata e in conclusione ma non per
ultimo
mi piace pensare alla giustizia
riparativa nel momento in cui una pena è
già stata applicata è eseguita è
scontata
magari in carcer di regola in carcere
dall autore di reato
in quel momento in cui lo stato mira
risocializzare l'autore di reato e non
c'è migliore risocializzazione di quella
che passa dalla ricomposizione della
relazione con la vittima non c'è
migliore responsabilizzazione di quella
che passa da un'azione positiva
dell'autore di reato perché l'obbedienza
obbliga ma non convince con la giustizia
riparativa finalmente l'autore di rato
può fare qualcosa attivamente
positivamente e non è un caso che siano
estremamente incoraggianti i risultati
che sono stati raccolti sul fronte della
recidiva cioè il tasso di ricaduta nel
reato recenti studi hanno evidenziato
una riduzione dell 84 per cento dei
tassi di recidiva per reati violenti che
sono stati in qualche modo trattati
anche con percorsi di giustizia
riparativa faccia a faccia tra autore e
vittima e poi non si tratta solo di
sentirsi su più sicuri come abbiamo
finora descritto ma si tratta di essere
più sicuri e quindi la giustizia
riparativa è la risposta alla domanda di
sicurezza
questo ci siamo chiesti probabilmente
non è l'unica risposta alla domanda di
sicurezza ma è una risposta importante
è una risposta che gli organismi
sovranazionali ci stanno sollecitando a
dare che l'italia ha dato troppo poco ma
che dobbiamo prendere sul serio oggi che
stiamo cercando risposte convincenti al
reato e che i cittadini ci chiedono
sempre con maggior forza di sentirsi più
sicuri
[Applauso]